[Captions by Y Translator]
There are a lot of things
you can capture on camera
that looks even cooler
if you can slow it down.
Well today, we're going
to take some gallium metal.
We're going to freeze it
extra cold in liquid nitrogen,
and then we're going to smash
it to see what that looks
like in super slow-mo.
[Music]
Guys, I'm here with Todd
and Joe from Kuma Films,
and they have some better
camera equipment than we do.
And so they're going
to help us out
with a little experiment today.
Guys, you want to explain
a little bit about
what you've got going on here.
So this is a Phantom
high-speed camera.
The specific model
is the VEO 640s,
and it can shoot upwards
of 50,000 frames a second.
So pretty slow.
That is absolutely insane.
So we've got our gallium,
we've got some liquid nitrogen,
and I want to see these things
explode just beautifully.
All right, let's take
our little gallium Lego man,
and send him on an adventure.
[Music]
Everyone's ready?
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
That's beautiful.
3, 2, 1.
That's gonna look good.
[Music]
Oh, that's so perfect.
I love watching
like the cracks appear
before it explodes.
But then like you see
the speed of your hammer,
like all that is actually slow.
Yeah.
All right, those two shots
were really cool.
We've got more of
these little gallium Lego men,
and we're going to do
pretty much the same thing,
but we're going to try
to zooming in,
and just like ultra macro shot,
where the the guy
is filling the whole frame.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Oh man, most of his body is
apparently intact somewhere.
I saw a very
large chunk fly off.
Oh, here it is.
[Music]
Look, it's his toes.
Lego man toes.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
I do love the massive
amounts of destruction.
The hammer does a pretty
good job of shattering these,
but we do want to try something
with a little bit more speed,
and see how that works out.
We've got a Han
Solo in carbonite.
This is going to be
really easy to hit.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Oh, wow!
Yeah.
That was beautiful.
[Music]
That well and truly
exploded, so much more
than I thought it was,
and I'm very happy
with the result.
That looks really cool.
[Music]
All right, smashing stuff
with a hammer has been
pretty great so far.
Now, I've just got
a mild steel rod,
and I'm going to see
if I can just whip right
through it because I'm curious
what will happen.
So our poor little
R2D2 is gonna...
He might not make it.
3, 2, 1.
I don't know what
the impact was.
So I want to see like,
did I just clip it?
Did I actually like
hit the middle of it?
[Music]
Yeah, I just clip the top
of his head and cracked it open.
That's why I didn't go flying.
[Music]
3, 2,1.
Just for a little bit of fun,
we are taking our camera
off of the tripod,
and we're trying for a little
bit of a parallax effect.
3, 2, 1. Go.
Might have been
a tiny bit early,
but I think you
still got pretty good.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Yeah, that one got
stopped for a second.
It's much more solid chunk.
[Music]
Awesome stuff.
Thank you to Todd
and Joe from Kuma Films.
Guys, if you have any other
stuff you want to see us film
in super slow motion,
let us know down
in the comments.
We love working with these guys.
You should go check
out their channels.
They've got some awesome stuff.
We put out a call
for you guys to send
him some questions.
We've gathered a bunch
of those up,
and now we're going
to be answering some of them.
Mr. Manvi.
Manvi?
Mr. Manvi?
Would like to know,
"Which is the
most longest project
that TKOR has done so far,
and can we expect another big
project coming sometime soon?
Such as the real-life treehouse
with the pulley system project."
Oh, good question.
The longest project,
dehydrating milk takes like,
took like three or four
days to just let
it dehydrate all the way,
but it wasn't like Hands-On
working and stuff.
You could talk about
the failed moss video.
Oh.
We at one point wanted to do
a test about moss graffiti.
If you've ever
researched Moss Graffiti,
you'll find about
a trillion pictures
that are just like these cool
designs made out of moss.
There's instructions and recipes
of how to make moss graffiti,
and like 99% of them are fake.
Like they didn't do it.
So they have a recipe
of it like, get some Moss,
get some milk,
get some dirt,
blend that all together,
and add some corn syrup,
and then paint that on.
And if you water
that twice a day
while give you just
the right amount of sun
and shade, you'll get...
It's...
None of it.
It's not true.
Almost everyone has faked it.
There's lots of videos out there
where people show doing this,
and it's fake.
Or they-- I've seen several
where they literally
like put a tripod,
and you can see
where they've painted it,
and it's just like brown goo.
And then they just CGI it green,
like, oh look,
it's our time lab,
but it was not a time lab.
They're just like,
and now it's green,
because maybe that would work,
but it doesn't.
It doesn't work.
There are a couple ways you
can do real moss graffiti.
A lot of those pictures
that are on Pinterest are
from a couple of artists
who would take sheets of moss,
usually real moss.
Sometimes artificial
moss or dead,
dried and painted moss.
They would take sheets of it,
and they would
carefully cut it out,
and then they would glue it on
so it looked like the moss
had grown like that.
But really, it was just
stuck on in place.
And then, I did see one user
who found a method
where you take I think glue
and shredded cotton,
and you attach that to a board,
and then you take like
moss seeds mixed with some dirt,
and you put
that into the cotton,
and the cotton
holds enough water,
and it holds the
seeds and everything,
and he got it to kind of work.
But it's a little unruly
if I'm remembering correctly.
Like the moss just
starts growing everywhere,
and leaves the boundaries
of whatever you tried
to draw or write.
So yeah, we tried
Moss Graffiti and I did it.
I tried like three different
types of moss with three or four
different recipes of moss,
and so I had like 20
like samples of moss,
and every single day
for two months,
I watered it,
and they were in a place
with a little bit of sun
and a little bit of shade,
and like nothing.
Like not even the tiniest
little sprout grew out of that.
And I'm not saying
it's completely impossible,
because maybe there are places
that would work.
Maybe there are other types
of moss that would work better.
Maybe if you live
somewhere like Seattle,
where it's just humid
and damp all the time,
because it's always raining,
it would work a lot better.
But that, we tried
that for like two months,
and got nowhere with it,
and I was hoping I could show
maybe one of them worked,
and I even tried like coming
with my own recipe
that I thought seemed
like it was the best
of all the worlds,
and then the ants
like eat it or something.
I don't know what happened,
but it was just...
Every day I'd go out,
and like less of it
would be there,
and I don't know where it went.
But Moss Graffiti,
so if anyone out there has
really truly done Moss Graffiti,
and it works, something,
I mean something you
can dip a paint brush in,
paint it on a wall,
and then water it,
and will grow as moss,
you let us know,
and we'll do a video on it.
Send you 25 bucks.
In terms of expecting
another big project
coming sometime soon.
We've always got big projects
that we want to do,
but big projects are
so time consuming,
which was what part of
what makes them big,
and we love doing them.
But one big project can easily
take up weeks of time,
and we put out
five videos a week.
And so if I do a big project
that's going to take two
or three weeks of my time to do,
that means I have
to somehow build a stockpile
of like 15 more videos,
and that's hard to do.
So there are different sizes
of videos coming all the time.
I don't have an estimate
for when we could do
the real life Treehouse.
Although I would love too,
that sounds super fun,
I don't currently have
a good tree for that.
That's one of
my limited factors.
Guys, if you've got
other questions you
want to see us answered
while we're doing this,
let us know.
We want to hear it from you.
Guys, that's it for today,
but that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video,
and you should go
check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you haven't subscribed
to our Channel yet,
I don't know what you're waiting for,
hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.